es una revolución que se ve mejor desde
lo alto los tejados de las casas
californianas están cubiertos de paneles
solares hace diez años menos de 100 mil
edificios estaban equipados con estos
mientras que ahora hay 1.300.000 un
aumento en la generación de energía
impulsado por numerosas suspensiones
esta ong que instala paneles
gratuitamente en barrios desfavorecidos
el año que empecé habíamos instalado
energía solar en unos 200 hogares aquí
cada año esa cifra ha ido creciendo y
este año mi equipo superó las 2.000
viviendas en la zona de los ángeles la
demanda se disparó
por la energía solar y la posibilidad
y el precio de los paneles bajó un 80
por ciento los últimos cinco años pero
la inversión sigue siendo de unos quince
mil dólares por hogar así que este
programa gratuito es una gran ayuda para
el propietario de esta casa que paga
mucho dinero por la electricidad un pago
mínimo 155 dólares por mes mon
es mucho si es mucho y ese valor va a
bajar a unos 30 dólares quizá menos así
que voy a ahorrar mucho dinero
él probablemente ahorrará a cerca de
1300 euros al año durante los próximos
20 años el sistema está garantizado
desde 2020 la ley californiana exige
incluso que las nuevas viviendas estén
equipadas con energía solar una norma
que también se aplicará a las oficinas y
comercios a partir de 2023 la transición
a la energía verde está muy avanzada ya
sea hidráulica solar o eólica a
california no le faltan recursos ni
voluntad política el estado se ha fijado
el objetivo de alcanzar el 100 por
ciento electricidad limpia para el año
2045 y algunas ciudades como los ángeles
ya se adelantaron y con joe podríamos
alcanzar este objetivo desde el 2035
pero para lograrlo hay que tener en
cuenta muchas cosas necesitaremos contar
con la infraestructura necesaria para
aumentar nuestra producción de energía y
eso incluye líneas de alta tensión y un
sistema de distribución eso va a costar
entre 57.000 y 87 mil millones de
dólares para que la electricidad siga
siendo asequible no es solo
descarbonizar el sector energético sino
también descarbonizar el sector del
transporte
más autos eléctricos significarían más
demanda de electricidad y por lo tanto
menores costos la ciudad de los ángeles
él lo comprendió y está instalando
cargadores rápidos gratuitos en los
hogares de los propietarios de los autos
eléctricos ecos de agua para que si yo
hubiera tenido que comprarlo me habría
costado unos 750 dólares más y
tratamientos dólares de instalación pero
la compañía eléctrica lo pagó para
animar a la gente a comprar autos
eléctricos así que fue completamente
gratis y lo tenemos desde hace 10 años
con sus ayudas california es el estado
con más vehículos eléctricos y sin
embargo sólo representan el 10 por
ciento de las ventas de autos nuevos
para richard sigue habiendo una
resistencia entre los consumidores que
puede explicarse fácilmente
aparte del precio creo que la principal
desventaja de los coches eléctricos al
menos para mí es cuando conduzco largas
distancias siempre me preocupa que vaya
a ver interiores
el estado de california cuenta con la
red de estaciones de recarga más
desarrollada del país con nada menos que
14 mil estaciones públicas pero cargar
un vehículo toma en promedio entre 3 y 4
horas y 30 minutos con los cargadores
más potentes sanz briz aridane
si alguien terminó de cargar pero
nuestro auto entonces tendré que esperar
a alguien que se fue de compras aquí
sencillamente no le importe que a pesar
de estos obstáculos el estado dorado lo
apuesta todo por los vehículos
eléctricos el gobernador incluso
prometió que éstos representarán el 100
por ciento al mercado de autos nuevos en
2035 y creo que va a ser muy difícil
alcanzar ese objetivo
vas a ser extremadamente costoso pero
hoy en día todavía se necesitan varios
miles de dólares de sus versiones y el
precio de los vehículos eléctricos pueda
competir con los de los vehículos a gas
gas
para hacer más atractivo el mercado de
los automóviles eléctricos california
confíe en su poder de innovación en el
sur de los ángeles esta empresa
emergente afirma haber encontrado la
solución al problema del tiempo de carga
en ebay recaudó más de 100 millones de
euros entre sus inversionistas para
crear un nuevo tipo de batería y habrá
no entre nuestros inversionistas se
encuentran alianza renault-nissan así
como lg y samsung con renault estamos en
proceso de firmar un importante acuerdo
para comercializar esta tecnología
en este laboratorio se está preparando
una pequeña revolución aquí el silicio
sustituye algunos de los minerales raros
utilizados en las baterías tradicionales
menos contaminantes estas nuevas
baterías son también más eficientes a
nadie se le condenará no nuestra
tecnología que utiliza a nodos de
silicio nos ha permitido crear lo que se
conoce como una carga ultra rápida en 5
minutos así que ahora podrá viajar y
cargar su auto muy rápidamente como 'la
que se llenará un tanque de gasolina
cárcel teniendo una innovación que
podría incorporarse a los autos nuevos a
partir del próximo año california quiere
mostrarle el camino al resto del país el
estado se había comprometido a volver a
los niveles de emisiones de gases de
efecto invernadero de 1990 para 2020
ganó la apuesta con cuatro años de
ventaja su próximo objetivo será reducir
sus emisiones en un 40% más para 2030